hello my name is margot warren
i'm the chief of the media relations
branch and a senior
advisor at the office of neuroscience
communications and engagement
otherwise known as once at ninds
so glad you have joined us today for
this workshop we had a few
communications workshops at the
at the pi meeting last year and they
were very popular so
welcome back i know it's the end of the
day thanks for sticking
around and you're good it's going to be
worth your while
this is the science communications
workshop the title of the talk
is stories about science narrative
methods in science communication and
correcting
misinformation so i want to give a
little plug to
offices like ours who do communications
full time
and please i know each of your
institutions have something like the
ones office
press media marketing we would love it
if you would get in touch with
with those people when you perhaps are
inspired
by the end of this workshop to want to
do a little more communicating
you have those professionals on hand to
to help you so today we have a wonderful
presenter liz neely i've heard her talk
you're in for a great treat
and liz is the executive director of the
story collider
it's a non-profit organization dedicated
to true
personal stories about science told live
on stage
previously liz studied behavior and
evolution
and has specialized in all aspects of
science communications in her career
she's done it all
liz has led the story collider for the
past five years
and she is also a lecturer at yale
university
so just a reminder please use the q a
box you can start loading it up with
questions throughout the presentation
and then liz and i will be back to
answer your questions live
thanks so much
about a month ago i received a text
message
from a group of friends and i read this
for your viewing pleasure if you have
time what do you think of this
and a link to a certain video
now infamous but i thought
oh no this is a
a piece of propaganda about an urgent
issue
that is facing the public when it comes
to science right now
about coronavirus and the funny thing is
i mean i am a person who not that long
ago
just wrote an entire piece about how to
talk about
coronavirus um and yet still getting
that message from my friend
felt challenging felt difficult
now um talking about science
communication is not exactly my
full-time job
i'm the executive director of a
storytelling organization
what consumes my days are um the idea of
taking scientists taking peoples whose
lives have been shaped by science
and putting them well used to be putting
them on stage
now on screen these are not ted talks or
anything like that there's no slides no
props it's just a single person
telling a 10 minute long story of
something that happened to them
in their life that ranges from hilarious
to heartbreaking
we record all of these stories and every
friday a new episode drops
on the story collider podcast this is my
co-host and my co-director in the
organization erin barker
i'm the one in the red dress and we kind
of represent the art
and the science sides of the
organization respectively
in addition to these sort of public um
experiences that we like to produce and
share
we also teach workshops and trainings
helping researchers and academics people
working in conservation or medicine or
engineering
learn how to do this stage based
performance so that's the background i
bring today
when i'm thinking about how we can apply
narratives
in our science communication and in
correcting misinformation
in the public sphere in addition to my
work at story collider though
the perspectives that i knit together
range from the kinds of committees that
i sit on around
public engagement with science and
technology at
aaas as well as from the aspen institute
my academic seat is at yale i'm a
lecturer
working with the national neuroscience
curriculum initiative
attempting to take cutting-edge
neuroscience research
and use compelling narratives to package
it into digestible
memorable talks
that help psychiatry residents
understand and appreciate neuroscience
and incorporate that into their own
clinical practice
and then finally the question of
misinformation is near and dear to my
heart as
one of the co-organizers of last april's
sackler colloquium hosted by the
national academy of sciences
on misinformation in the public sphere
and so when i think about the problems
that we collectively face whether you're
a researcher you're working in
government you're someone who's just
very interested in
in sharing accurate science i think it's
most important for us to appreciate that
there are
these two dimensions that i mentioned
that we are combining
theory and practice this was something i
needed as someone who was trained in
science coming into
this space i've spent the past 15 years
or so
combing through the literature reading
papers and risk communication
and then psychology and a little bit of
neurocognitive science but also
just trying to wrap my head around the
question of
what do we what do what does the
scientific research community
understand about how people make sense
of the world around them
and how they process information how
they make decisions
so i think that is most useful to us
now my problem was i entered this
tech quest with an incredibly simple
mental model
of my challenge i thought i want to
understand
how to get people to trust me or trust
science trust scientists
i will go read the research on trust or
whatever else it might be
and i will get an answer and i thought
this was going to be a very linear
pathway but any of us who've ever worked
in research
recognized this is frankly ludicrous
right um the reality is that i went down
many many pathways and all that's
happened is i've recognized there is a
substantial gap between theory and
practice become
between the kind of research that's
being done and the kinds of questions
that i was asking um and so i think
that for those of us who are interested
in these questions of how can we be
effective and ethical
in our science communication whether
that's using stories or any other format
it's important to think about how we
apply that research that we're drawing
from
so i'll keep this brief but a framework
that i found
really helpful is on using academic
theories in practice
and it lays out these three sort of
approaches instrumental conceptual and
translational approaches
of using the research
using academic products exploring
uh content of interest to us and trying
to apply it
in our daily lives because that's what
we're doing here right like you're
sitting in this talk listening to me
right now because you want to
leave at the end of it both being
introduced to interesting questions
getting a sense of what the literature
is and like where
opportunities might be but more
practically
asking how do you for example
answer your colleagues or your friends
or your family
you applying those principles
so what i feel like we can say with the
most
certainty in all of the reading across
many disciplines many which are not
speaking to each
other um is that perhaps the single most
consistent
thing that we understand is that human
beings
in general struggle to understand what
other people
think and why we overestimate how men
how much agreement people have with us
or
um we overestimate how highly they think
of us
um the ways in which we get this wrong
would be
laughable if the stakes weren't so
incredibly
high one of the big
problems i see with this is that those
of us who
are trained in the hard sciences or who
come from research backgrounds
tend to fall into the making the same
mistakes over and over again and one of
those is the idea that
if we face an apathetic or oppositional
audience the solution is simply to give
them data
because surely the problem is
understanding and if only they had
sufficient information they would agree
with our interpretation of it
right does that familiar sound familiar
to you
i know i made that mistake early in my
career that idea is called
the information deficit model it
presumes that people are empty vessels
that just need to be
filled and that is a zombie
idea it is a stinking shambles that
follows me around
the best available communications
research and science
tells us that simply attempting to quote
unquote educate or throw more data
at people who are not already inclined
to agree with us or trust us
is a fool's errand now this is not to
say that the data doesn't matter it
absolutely excruciatingly does
and so for example in particular if i'm
asking the question of how do we
effectively talk about something like
the global pandemic we're all
currently experiencing i think it's
essential that we look
to rigorous valid data sets um similar
to for example corona data us which is
um being run by dr
red bird out of northwestern university
surveying more than 200 people every day
about
attitudes beliefs and their current
reality this kind of foundational
understanding of what attitudes and
opinions
and if the fact of the matter are is
essential
just as many other kinds of scientific
facts that you may be trying to
communicate but here's the thing
if we understand anything we understand
that you cannot displace complex
and especially not strong feelings
with simple facts and one of the
clearest
sort of ways of thinking through this
because i remember
rejecting this idea early on and saying
the facts matter
we have to have a shared basis of our
understanding of reality
um the way to kind of get into this if
you're having
that kind of strong emotional reaction
is to think about risk in particular
when people ask me um of all of the
hundreds of papers that are
in my shared zotero library online which
i would love to read with you if you
want to talk about them
you know sort of where do they start
what's the one thing that they should
read
i point them to um baruch fischoff's
classic paper from 1995
um and it is about 20 years of
risk communication and it lays out
his core argument that ontology
recapitulates
phylogeny and what he's saying is that
every time a new group of scientific
experts
discover that they have a risk
communication problem
they reinvent the wheel they go through
the same process of thinking well all we
need to do
is to get the numbers right and you've
seen us scrambling to do that
and then we think oh well all we have to
do is tell them the numbers
uh perhaps we need to put those numbers
into context that they understand
and especially maybe we should show them
that they have accepted similar risks
in the past or all the time and then we
continue down this pathway and saying
okay well
we should show them that this is fair or
is this a smart trade-off or judgment
um we should be kind and perhaps
collaborative
we need to make them partners perhaps we
need to tell them stories
the thing is over and over again we see
communities of experts
wasting time figuring out what the
communication research
tells us and a visual for that helped me
kind of wrap my head around this
is that if we think about how
people make sense of a risk situation
a consequentialist perspective would
imagine that we do
extensive cognitive elaboration so we're
thinking hard
and we're thinking about the probability
of um
an outcome and there's a subjective
layer to it of like whether how
how bad it might be and that as a result
of our cognitive evaluation we
simultaneously experience feelings but
then also make a decision
functionally this assumes that people
are rational actors
and i think all of us can appreciate um
this is the equivalent of you know the
spherical cow
assumption in physics i think
a better approach or understanding of
risks is this
a risks as feelings perspective in which
we still see those anticipated outcomes
and subjective probabilities
experiencing going through cognitive
evaluation but also we know that
external factors just everything else
that you're coping with your available
attention the
vividness of the risk presented to you
the immediacy of the threat as you
experience influences
both your thoughts and your feelings
about
this and both of those lead to the
judgment
that you come to to the decision that
you make
a more crass way of putting this but
hopefully more memorable is something i
cannot believe i ever got through peer
review but in a book chapter
i captured the idea as follows so
risk is a social construct it is not
something that is objective or can be
measured
independent of the individuals who are
making that judgment of risk
and it is perceived hazard
times outrage or for those of you who
are very online
as i am at the moment we can say this by
saying risk equals omg
times wtf right hazard
and outreach hazard can take
many different forms too and one of the
most important things i think we need to
grapple with and what was really
enlightening for me early on in my
career when i was trying to understand
why people are not didn't seem to be
rational didn't seem to be paying
attention to the data in the way i
wanted them to
is to appreciate that our conversations
about science are not
existing in a vacuum they happen in the
reality of our world
and the reality of our world is that our
identities
our political opinions our ideological
stances
all get entangled with how we interpret
signals and this leads to a situation
which is called
identity threat it's the idea that
if i tell you my position on certain hot
button topics like climate change for
example or
it used to be the case vaccination was
partially
polarized like this that we knew what
your political
identity was and we have
all too often i'm afraid in science um
adapted this rhetoric of us versus them
of like an anti-science public that just
rejects
rational thinking and data because we
have
seen some of this behavior in highly
polarized topics
but this is an empirical question and i
look to work by
dan kahan for example and others showing
that we have to understand
the specific question specific
arena the topic that we are looking at
these rainbow charts behind him are
um different issue areas global warming
um nanotechnology for example and it
shows you
that we don't see strong polarization
across every science
topic we have to treat each one
separately and this is where we need the
social science data
to help us be effective
the other way that we can be effective
in science communication
if you do not have that data available
to you
is to look to personal narratives and
this is where our work comes in
so in my on my stages in our podcast
we have experts we have scientists we
have people
talking about topics like climate change
and coral bleaching
um about lgbtq identity and coming out
and what it is like
to have a minority sexual orientation
in a world that doesn't accept that we
have stories about police brutality
and violence we have stories about
animal experimentation we have stories
about abortion literally every
issue that you know would cause the
largest
amount of emotional argumentation stoic
glider produces stories about them
and we don't experience massive amounts
of blowback
part of the reason in this is that when
information is packaged in a way that is
a personal lived experience
when people are paying attention to this
is what happened to me this is what i
felt this is what i saw
it's not functioning as the same kind of
identity threat
as claims to this is how the world
actually is
and you and your entire political party
are
wrong and so really as a pragmatic issue
i look to stories as a way to help me
lower those perceived threats to
identity
and help people connect to the ideas
that we want to talk about
so let's focus on effective science
communication
when i ponder the question of
what how do i define this for me it
comes down to three things
what i want to have at the end of the
day
is that the understanding of my audience
person walks away with an understanding
that is correct
it helps me personally to distinguish
between accuracy
and precision but with a focus on
accuracy
is the information correct then second i
have the question of
is it going to be retained have i
managed to
create a memorable experience so that
sometime in the future
someone will say oh yes i know that
rather
than oh someone told me about that once
but i can't remember what they said
and then finally that the framework
of analysis i have helped sort of
um integrate into this person's
worldview endures
and this is really important because i
think audiences
who are not used to being involved in
research themselves
can feel quite frustrated when it feels
like there's just
um contradictory studies coming out one
says this is good for you one says this
is bad for you and they think oh well
scientists don't know what they're
talking about instead i'm very
interested in helping people appreciate
why and how we come to the conclusions
that we do and so thinking about
narratives for example as a way to share
the process
of science is so much more powerful and
lasting in that enduring sense
than simply communicating the products
of that research and so for me the
reason that i
have invested the past five years of my
career at story collider and in
storytelling specifically
is that when it comes to these goals
the communications research suggests
that stories or narratives
are processed by a privileged cognitive
pathway
people listen to them and interpret them
differently they engage with them
differently than they do with
evidence-based argumentation and as a
result
of the particular kind of processing
that human beings use in a narrative
sense we see several outcomes when
stories are more interesting
they're more engaging people want to
listen to them they want to start
listening to them they want to keep
listening to them
more than anything else they are more
comprehensible
this surprised me to learn that people
understand
better when information is presented in
a narrative format as opposed to just a
strict chronology or bullet points or
statistics
people understand the information better
as a story and then of course for my
interests they are found to be more
believable
as well as more persuasive for those
skeptical audiences
understanding this means a lot to me
because it helps me appreciate and take
a step back
from for example we know that humans are
cognitive misers
we will minimize the amount of directed
effort that we have to undertake
in order to take new information and
slide it into existing world use
we call these heuristics you can call
them biases they're mental shortcuts
and what you see here is a beautiful
visualization
of just some of the several hundred
kinds of
cognitive biases that have been
identified and we can zoom in on one
quadrant that currently feels
quite relevant where there's a glut of
information but not enough meaning
and we know that humans tend to fall to
make kinds of mistakes like
we imagine patterns where there aren't
any
we simplify probabilities and numbers to
make them easier to think about
and so early in my career i hoped that
understanding these biases and
particularly understanding like the
the neurological substrates and
correlates of these things like
brain science i thought could help me
understand
people like i wanted to know okay what
fear
circuitry is triggered by a rhetoric
that evokes threats and how can we use
positive narratives to counter
that that kind of thing there is amazing
work
being done in this spaces and i'm also
really excited about the kinds of work
coming out of like the hasson lab and
um jack gohan's lab and people who are
doing neuroimaging studies and
understanding what's happening in the
brain as we listen to stories
i love that stuff but i think it can be
just
a distraction because we have to
remember that human
beings are not isolated brains we are
individuals who are deeply embedded in
social networks
that shape our our experience of reality
and our understanding of it
so we have to take into account um
psychology and also sort of mass
behavior
if we want to get at why do people do
what they do why do they think what they
think
there are a few practical resources that
i want to just take a moment to point to
because i think they're really helpful
in moments like this and i'm glad i got
my hands on them
they include things like um the
debunkers handbook and also the
conspiracy theory
handbook uh cook and lewandowski in
particular
are authors that have been important in
helping me understand
what how do we translate the academic
research on
conspiracy thinking or on correcting
misinformation
to allow us to do these things
efficiently
and if you only remember one thing from
this talk
it's that please do not repeat
a piece of information in order to
attempt to correct it
because you are inadvertently
normalizing it by making it sound more
common more frequent which taps into a
bias
that makes it feel more correct
when i think about storytelling though
there's there's quite a gap in the
research here i don't have
i can't give you citations about
specifically
powerful sound bites of how stories help
counteract information
so i need to walk you through sort of
the theory that i use
so for example i look to papers like
this one from
nabi and green which are looking at the
role of emotion
in narratives so the ups and downs that
a storyteller
or a character in a piece experiences as
we
listen to the plot unfold and here you
can see figure one
where we've got narrative transportation
that delicious feeling of being sucked
into a story
um having a sort of a positive feedback
cycle
with emotional shifts so when the story
is sad
we feel sad right the more deeply you
are involved in the story the sadder you
feel
or the happier you feel whatever it
might be and then that leads to a
specific
sort of set of behaviors that we want to
encourage
those include information seeking
repeated viewing
social sharing and memory so in other
words
powerful stories that involve emotional
ups and downs
so that's the craft of storytelling
don't necessarily
teach people something they don't imbue
a specific concept or
change their mind even but they do lead
to these indirect outcomes
that i think are ultimately more
empowering they
they get people to talk about what
they've heard they encourage them to go
seek more on their own
and to review the material again and to
remember it in the future
this i think is a powerful goal and a
powerful outcome
so the final piece of what i want to be
thinking about together today is the
question of okay so
we've explored a bit what effective
science communication looks like
and how stories can be an one effective
pathway
to our collective goals but
there's another piece to this as well
and that's ethical
science communication
for me a simple visual helps kind of
capture the idea of what i'm asking here
so if i show you this
little doodle and ask you what it is
you might tell me you might also think
okay
once i know what it is it's my job to
tell other people what it is
but i think the reality is that we live
in complex ambiguous
worlds and it's not that there is one
determined answer knowledge is
contextual
information um is contingent and so
what i think of science communication
and my personal goal
is to help people make sense of the
context to be able to interpret
material the ideas the facts the data
whatever it is that we have
rather than just unquestioningly believe
it
fortunately there are also papers and
people who are studying
these questions of ethical communication
practices and specific to my focus on
narratives and service of this i look to
papers like this one from michael
dalstrom and shirley ho that's looking
at ethical considerations of using
narrative to communicate
science what i like in their framework
in particular
was it introduced the idea that you
could in theory have a particular
anecdote
one story that was factually correct all
the way through
and yet it could still be mis it could
be misrepresenting
the overall picture if it's an extreme
outlier
so i think about stories needing not
only to be verifiably true
in the plot of them and the details of
them but also representative
of our best current understanding of
reality
i also am i'm a practical person a
pragmatic person so i really appreciate
other research approaches to this um
like
this one where we see starboard
laying out a decision framework of how
do you decide
when to correct misinformation in
online spaces because sometimes the
ethical question is
am i obligated to correct it every time
i see
a mistake or i see an argument that is
not
correct and i think frameworks like this
can help us manage
our our energy our own emotions
and also be more effective and ethical
as we move through our online and
in-person spaces
i have another sort of set of three
guidelines that help sum up what i think
of when i think of
ethical science communication and sort
of what i've packaged this talk around
so for me ethical science communication
includes three
components again one is that it respects
the
agency of the audience this is the
difference between
persuasion which i think is a valid and
legitimate goal
versus manipulation in which you are
just trying to achieve
compliance for example or uh
attitudinal change without any kind of
respect for the people that you're
trying to
whose minds you're trying to change so
recognizing that
your audience has valid questions and
perspectives to bring into this space
and um is able to make up their own
minds rather than just
they're not children even children
should be treated with
respect i think also ethical science
communication
appreciates the relative position of the
expert
this for me is important in questions of
like are you a member of the community
that you're trying to
um educate or convince to do something
um are you someone who is a member of a
group that has historically
been very privileged um speaking to
communities that have been
marginalized that have been oppressed
that have been silenced
appreciating that not all of us are
meeting each other
um on equal footing is really important
and then finally in terms of being
ethical in our science communication
i think this one's easy for all of us
who have trained in
science and come from research
backgrounds it's we must be
clear about the limitations of the data
and never overreach what the science
says
i think it's appropriate and sometimes
even necessary in the kind and ethical
thing to do
to say look we don't know the answer
ours
we don't have the data yet my personal
take on this or how i'm coping with it
at the moment
is but in order to answer that question
we would need the following things
that to me is a form of ethical science
communication
and what i'm ultimately pushing towards
what i'm
hoping that we can accomplish whether
you're using stories or not
in setting up the ways you're
approaching either the science
communication of your own discipline
your own expertise your own papers
or things far outside your field but you
are a scientist moving through the world
who is representing
a scientific viewpoint is that i think
the idea of deliberative discourse
is a powerful one i don't merely want to
change someone's mind i want to lead
them i want to build a process
through which they change their own mind
and they are able to think more clearly
in the future as it may allow
in order to do this in order to have
deliberative discourse
we need four things one is accurate
information
which can be a challenge for certain
um but i think this for us in many
instances the people watching this
we can feel reasonably satisfied that we
have a best approximation
of this through peer review through the
processes that make science
self-correcting
we have some sense of what is accurate
then we also need to make sure that
especially if we are talking about
shifting community perspectives
or that of more than a single individual
that we have representative diversity
and i mean this in every sense of the
world different perspectives different
lived experiences
people of all different kinds coming
together because that variety of
response reaction and analysis
perspective
context helps really make this
a legitimate conversation we also need
to
have the parties entering in a
deliberative stance
this means that there's mutual respect
and that you're
living the ideal of science that you
will change your mind
if the data dictates that you will
listen to the points that your
you know audience or your partner in the
conversation are making
um you will acknowledge
when you don't know and this
i think is easy to to slide away from
ourselves when we feel frustrated or
under attack
or like someone just isn't listening and
and they're not
being uh based in reality and they're
not being logical
it's easy to slip out of that
deliberative stance it's hard to
acknowledge when you don't know things
it's hard to change your mind or to
signal that you can
but just a small amount of reciprocal
sort of exchange can go a long way
toward legitimizing a dialogue
and then finally this is a hard one is
we know that any kind of
meaningful exchange takes time
and so for me this this goes towards the
fact that like we cannot
be all things to all people there's an
xkcd cartoon that always makes me laugh
of a little figure
typing on a computer and there's a voice
from the other room saying honey come to
bed and they say i can't
someone on the internet is wrong
for me this also helps keep clearly in
mind what i'm attempting to achieve in
any conversation it's not that i
necessarily need to
win i think winning is a damaging
framework
but rather that i show people that i
respect them
i explain where i'm coming from i bring
the best available
data or science or information to the
table
i surround myself with different kinds
of perspectives
and i acknowledge that life is long we
cannot reliably ever trace
a particular decision or moment to a
specific thing that someone said
that makes for good storytelling that's
rarely the reality
of it you you may feel like you've lost
an argument or you've
failed in attempting to share your
science with someone
but if you are approaching it from this
place of deliberative discourse
of ethical storytelling ethical science
communication
you may very well have set them up for a
slow
you know slow movement towards some kind
of future change
and i think that's worth your time
as i come to a close i just want to say
um
my biggest frustration in science
communication and science storytelling
and all of this space
is the ways in which i see knowledge
siloed
and the ways in which we fail to
capitalize on all of the rich
intellectual discourse
and work that has already been done that
we can apply
to the questions that face us especially
when the stakes are so high
i encourage you to be thinking and
reading
broadly and to draw from the disciplines
that know the most
so for example for those of us who are
thinking like oh how do i become an
effective science communicator if that's
not my primary job well for example i
think looking to
the informal science educational sphere
and realm
can be most helpful looking to the way
that teachers
are trained can be helpful and in all of
these spaces what we recognize
is that we need iteration and so i hope
you approach your science communication
your storytelling in the same way
that you learn about the theory and the
empirical information
some of the papers i was showing you or
that sort of thing
that you practice that you go from
thinking about it to actually doing it
and then that you take and incorporate
feedback of
was that successful did that make things
worse
was your conversational partner engaged
or were they bored
and then you feed that back into your
cycle
so that you develop a reflective process
in improving your ability to be ethical
and effective in your communications
so i'll bring this back to that moment
where i sat there
with my phone in my hand looking at a
text message my friend had sent me
that i felt
worried me and challenged my ability to
communicate about
the particular science that this time
was about coronavirus but it could have
been anything
in my essay at the atlantic i say that
there are sort of
four quick things that you can do to
help
brace yourself for this task
the first is to start where you
are to appreciate like i said what is
your position
as an expert relative to the person
who's asking
um to also recognize the limits of your
current knowledge
and to build on shared foundations that
you already
have to realize that in order to be an
effective communicator
you do not need to build an audience
of hundreds of thousands of people but
rather
you already are a trusted node in the
networks
of your friends your families they're
paying attention to you
and this is a place where you can make
immediate and perhaps
profound and lasting impact so start
where you are
the second thing is about picking your
battles
there are plenty of ideological and
political
battles we need to have when the stakes
are life and death
it's never more important to be able to
argue our values
and to do so passionately but it's
critical to disentangle when we're doing
that
from when we're attempting to
communicate science
and we know that when we start
a science communication conversation by
inadvertently triggering all these
identity protective mechanisms that that
limits
the ability to actually have any kind of
exchange
there's this is also the place where you
need to take stock of your reality
i mean we are all in front of our
computers right now you may have small
children at home you may be coping with
coronavirus yourself there's so many
different things going on
it's okay to draw boundaries around when
you're going to engage
and when you're not and to focus on the
places where you can make the most
impact
so for example there's a climate change
communication framework
called six americas that uses social
science data to break down
where people the bins that people fall
into in order to direct
the time and effort at sort of the the
large proportion of people
who may be persuaded who are uncertain
who want more information
rather than our instinct to just argue
with the trolls
so pick your battles wisely the third
thing is about
avoiding unforced errors i mean
i sort of referenced that already in
terms of accidentally triggering
identity protective mechanisms but
there's other things that we do as well
our instincts do not necessarily serve
us at all
when it comes to correcting
misinformation in particular
or maybe even being persuasive what you
don't want to do
is accidentally make something someone
worry about something
that they hadn't worried about before
that's called a boomerang effect
you don't want to further entrench or
exacerbate
an existing conflict you also don't want
to
accidentally make the piece of
misinformation
feel more common because you've repeated
it
you also don't want to undermine trust
because you've given too many arguments
and we know that there are cognitive
biases that say well one strong argument
is better than four arguments
the final thing here is about
this is your own reflective practice
this should be easy for all of us it is
absolutely what we aspire to
in any kind of science and science
communication which is to be
honest not only with our conversational
partners our audiences our communities
but also with ourselves to be
transparent about the limits of our
knowledge
to um this will also help keep you
honest
yourself i'm now repeating myself but
the idea is like
if you interrogate the boundaries of
your own knowledge and you recognize
where your own understanding
is limited you're doing this all the
time in your research
practice in your science communication
space it can help
make sure that you are giving accurate
information
as well as being that good partner
being that sort of honest broker of
information
so in the end what i want to say is
when i transitioned from science and
science communication
into storytelling i have to say you know
the word itself story storytelling
it used to set my teeth on edge i didn't
like it i was trained
in evolution i was used to hearing
stories in a negative sense like just
those stories
i was thinking that storytelling was
equivalent to hand waving that it was
what you did when your data wasn't
compelling
and so you wanted to sort of nudge
people into your preferred
interpretation
like a cheat that evoking an emotional
reaction was somehow manipulative or
inappropriate that it wasn't something
serious science scientists did
or you know really at the bottom of it i
was a
person who desperately wanted to live
the life of the mind
and i wanted to distance myself from
childish things and stories sound like
you know fairy tales or folk tales
but now as i've done all this reading as
i've matured as i've watched this as
i've developed a practice
fed by both you know hard-earned
stagecraft as well as
the best available academic approaches
i tend to think of narratives as stories
and
and the rigor of science is being
orthogonal
if you imagine two axes in space where
across the x we have
rigor so on the right hand side of the
screen is what we are all
attempting to achieve the best possible
science that
best the best way we have of describing
reality and on the y-axis we'll call
this narrative
so really good stories up at the top and
low narrative quality down at the bottom
i think we can imagine these different
quadrants
um up at the top left we have
entertainment
sure it doesn't really matter if the
details are right because it's an
amazing movie
or oh my goodness did you see this
week's episode
if we have neither rigor nor narrative
that's just noise there's plenty of that
on the internet
if we have plenty of scientific rigor
but very low narrative quality well
that's that's data
i would not even say that that's
scientific papers because
scientific papers all include
argumentation all the way throughout
they give us analysis and interpretation
but what i think
collectively those of us in the room
today are many different rooms but in
the shared online space today
um our goal is that we can tell
wonderful stories about the best most
interesting most
innovative research and whether that's
about brains
or any other topic it might be possible
i hope you leave this session
knowing that you have stories to tell
those stories are powerful they can
change the way
that people see scientists they can
challenge
old long-standing stereotypes about
who gets to be a scientist how you how
you work
what you're like and perhaps most
importantly
they can illustrate the process of
science the culture of science
all of the frustration and the beauty
and the elegance and the
terror everything that makes this
career this life that you've chosen
so powerful you can tell those stories
thank you for listening to me and uh
we would now like to open this up for
live
questions
hi everybody welcome i'm
joined by liz now
and she's here to answer your questions
one list it's
how did you actually respond to
um a friend who shared the plan pandemic
video on social
and might believe it but is not
interested in reading any fact-checking
sources
i love this question so thank you for
asking it
um for me there my brain is going
through
a whole number of questions of the
my friend the situation and myself in a
moment
so i want to first distinguish between
misinformation and disinformation
so misinformation is anything that's
wrong this information is a deliberate
attempt
to mislead i would want to make sure
that i appreciate
is it that my friend just happens to
believe this thing or are they pushing
some agenda that would guide my response
i also think that we have to remember
that
we may have multiple goals or diverging
goals it might be
that this is a dear friend of mine who i
care about and i want them to understand
and appreciate why this video is a
problem
it also might be that i think i can't
convince
this particular friend on this thing
right now but
i know that we're not only having a
conversation between the two of us but
we're signaling
to everyone who's watching so
your communication style the way you
relate with your friends
is unique and authentic to who you are
and what that looks like
for me i would sort of go through
context and you know and it would be i
would open by saying like if i decided
i'm going to respond to this in whatever
social media platform it is
it could be like you know you and i have
argued about this
for years and i know you are ready for
what i'm going to say next
um you can validate that friend and say
like one of the things i admire so much
about you
is like your desire to get to the bottom
of a mystery
or um how strong of an advocate
you are for you know people who
who've been harmed or something like
that but then then we're going back to
like communications basics to say like
but when i see you posting things like
this
it makes me angry or it makes me feel
worried because
and then you can fill in what your exact
issue is with sharing that particular
piece of information
um i personally tend to like to give
people
um opportunities to save face especially
if you are in social media forums
this is a friend um you know people that
you've got an audience who are observing
your interactions
i would much rather give people the
benefit of the doubt and a graceful way
out
and then back them into a corner um
and finally the thing that i like to
keep in mind for this was a book that
my co-director of the story collider
introduced me to it's called
radical candor by kim scott and it's the
idea that you care personally
but confront directly and
that for me is how i would actually talk
to
a friend someone who's important in my
life if they were sharing a piece of
propaganda or misinformation
thanks thanks liz um here's another
question
what do you think was the best
communication and the first
communication piece on covid19
um i think that's an impossible question
to answer as opposed but i really
appreciate the
the tenor and intention of it so um
admitting i am biased here because uh
the journalist i'm going to mention is
my husband in fact um uh ed young
at the atlantic has had a whole series
of
long reads about covid and one of my
favorites was
why is this all so confusing um
so what he's doing is attempting to
cover science that is a complex story
that is still unfolding in real time
that we may not have clear answers to
actionable
questions yet um by giving people a
framework
that they can use to understand so it's
not merely
you know he also wrote another piece
called uh everyone thinks they're right
about masks
and this was back when there was a lot
more uncertainty about whether or not we
should be wearing masks
um and instead of trying to say you
should do this or you should do that
he gave um hungry audiences a way to
make sense
of the information that they were seeing
that validates why there is this
difference of opinion
and so i think that kind of work is
outstanding
um the kind of coverage that i think is
damaging is um
uh the kind of like tick-tock journalism
that just covers
new pre-prints uncritically or or worse
you know um report out a press release
from an institution
without any kind of analysis or outside
uh
peer review or the scientific process
because i think that can be exhausting
and it adds to confusion and
misinformation
even if it's well intentioned
all right thanks liz here's another good
question
um sorry can't get my
three now okay so
um someone would like to know
how you establish trust with someone
who has anti-science views that seems to
be the
key to getting them to listen yeah
i mean so let's all let's all be honest
with ourselves
um attempting to get someone to trust
you
in the middle of an argument when
they're a stranger that you've had no
connection with in the past
that's asking a lot especially um
just given that the tenor of arguments
that are happening around
many of these issues um i absolutely
think that the ways
we can and should be doing this is to
become more trustworthy
so i talk about this being honest and
transparent in your answers
admitting where the bounds of your
knowledge are not only to your audience
but also to yourself
as you work to expand them um
identifying the difference between when
you have
a value value-driven or an emotional
response
to a particular part of the conversation
versus what we actually know as
researchers or scientists i think is
important
i i am always a proponent of
building uh relationships with other
people who already are trusted within
their
community who can because we can think
about amplifying other messages
rather than attempting to um one-on-one
build trust with people who have maybe
good reasons not to trust us quite
frankly
i think being able to interrogate why
there is that current lack of trust
and um like i said in the keynote um
recognizing that uh claiming there is a
generalized anti-science
added worldview is not well supported by
any of our available data on how people
actually
are making sense of things most people
want to say that their worldview is
backed up by science um they may
question
the um motivations and behaviors
of people who have conventional
expertise and credibility
but that's legitimate and i think
especially appreciating and recognizing
um those those underlying causes of
whatever distrust might be there
is uh a really important first step and
towards mending a relationship
here's another one uh my experience is
that people react differently to spoken
versus written community
do you have specific advice for
responding and writing rather than in
conversation
oh thank you for making me think about
that
um i don't actually i don't have
research that i can think of
that shows how we would do that um
i tend to feel and this is only based on
my
lived experience that
whether i'm talking to strangers on
social media or to my
friends and family that
the jargon and academic language that i
use to
telegraph expertise and credibility when
i'm
on camera like this or on on stage or in
a professional setting
doesn't always serve me well
and the more that i try to
write and speak the way that i do in
typical conversation
so that um my identity as someone who
cares about science
is not removed from my core identity as
their friend or colleague or daughter
whatever it might be
that it helps integrate these parts of
me uh
it helps position the information that
i'm trying to share
uh with all of who i am
and i do think that that part is
important and i know i'm dodging the
question
here i am partially i'm trying to buy
time and let my brain
tick and just think have i read or seen
anything that would be interesting and
helpful for us
i'm not i'm coming up short but um one
of the things i wanted to mention to
everyone who is watching
is you heard me in the presentation
mention that i have a publix zotero
library
of research publications um
uh and i'm going to look to see if i can
find any in this area
we're going to share that link it'll pop
up in the chat that won't be enduring
but we will also make sure that
we share this with all of you if you are
interested in
the evidence base for this communication
advice
that we are giving here
i think here is another one could you
speak
specifically about how you communicate
regarding issues like
animal experimentation yeah
so
all of these um
i don't know if they polarized because
this isn't a typically a typical example
of a polarized
scientific issue but it is very
emotionally heated
the people who are coming into a
conversation
have a certain set of expectations about
how scientists behave
how they reach their how they do
research how they reach conclusions
and how they're going to behave um
i think one of the powerful things you
can do
is disrupt those expectations
so one thing that we see is people who
have not done
animal research themselves are not um
connected to it personally
they think oh my goodness in order to do
this you must be a
callous cold person who just doesn't
care
about the animals you know in your in
your work
the scientists i know who conduct animal
research that couldn't be farther from
the truth
and typically they attempt to
emotionally distance themselves because
that is what is required
um to do their jobs but also to present
their work to their peers
and but by being able to share
what the toll this takes on them um
and why they still believe it's so
important to do
that helps move into that personalized
storytelling narrative space of
here's what i think about here's what's
going on inside my mind or behind the
scenes and here's why i
choose to take on this sacrifice to make
these decisions
it doesn't mean that everyone's going to
necessarily agree with you
but it certainly shifts the debate away
from
um sort of typical talking points that
people might be much more used to
hearing
um and also discrediting whereas when
you talk about your own choices
and your own experiences um
that has so much more validity because
you're talking about what you yourself
have gone through and believe
thanks um do you have a method for
finding a story to tell
figuring out what will make a good story
oh my goodness
um yes and no
so i am not a natural-born um performer
a lot of my friends and colleagues are
you know they're they're comedians
they're
they're actors they are story
professional storytellers and they are
just incredible wells of information
of stories it seems like they come up
with them all the time
and especially early on in my tenure at
story collider i was so frustrated
because i thought like how can i
how can i do this like i i want to tell
stories i like listening to them
i believe they are important but i've
when i come to myself it's just like
everything i've ever done
escapes my head and i feel stuck
so um there is a
many many time award-winning storyteller
named matthew dix
who has a technique he calls homework
for life
he keeps a spreadsheet i love a good
spreadsheet or a database
and every day he puts down just one
single thing that happens to him that
day that could be the basis
of a story in the future so it's kind of
like journaling
or keeping a diary and he argues that
this helps
give his days more like granularity
especially as he's a parent of young
children he says the days can just blur
the
months and years can go by but by doing
this he remembers those moments
um as they happen things that have
emotional resonance
to him and we often find so the story
collider does in fact offer trainings
and workshops for
faculty researchers scientists in
particular because
we are the people who've never been
trained how to do this and actively
trained against it
and so this is one of the biggest pain
points um in the process and it was
something i really wanted to figure out
how do we do this
part of it is getting out of your own
head and allowing yourself
to be creative free of the judgment that
we typically are you know sort of going
through i know i do this all the time
like
well i could tell a story about that oh
but that's probably not important enough
i or how would i get a message in there
um
put that aside and then we start looking
at strong emotional resonance
where are what are moments in your
scientific career
where you have been enraged
or so curious you couldn't stand it
or shocked or joyful
or sorrowful um we know
emotions are really important in
storytelling for a whole variety of
reasons
but we also experience strong emotions
when the stakes are really high
and this means this makes for good
storytelling that tension when you don't
know how something is going to go
and the consequences are very dire
that is typically a great place to look
for
story content and then honestly the best
thing is
having an outsider that you know like we
use
our team of producers and story coaches
um are trained to do this we're asking
what were you thinking
why did you do that what happened next
um
and being able to see the outside
perspective because we take for granted
so much
that we do and think um and we would
presume
everyone would behave the way that we
behave but that's not true this is what
makes storytelling and science
storytelling
in particular so delightful is that
all of the processing that you're doing
as you face a decision
um the options that you went through and
discarded before you took an action
that shows like the scientific process
in action
that shows your unique and idiosyncratic
approach to the kind of research that
you do and
those are the kinds of things that i
think make for excellent stories whether
they're big
or just tiny little moments in
our careers thanks liz well we are
just about out of time and um just
wanted to ask you one more question
in spite of some scientists will still
think talking to the public is a big
waste of time
how would you answer that i mean
so i really think this is about
an alignment between our behavior and
our expressed values
so on one hand i can make the same
pragmatic arguments that have been made
in so many formats so many times
more powerfully than i can make it today
but if your research is taxpayer funded
you
owe an explanation to the people who are
making this possible
i also think it goes towards the valid
like the sort of social legitimacy
of science as an enterprise if you want
people
to appreciate and support and buy into
this
we need to make them part of it listen
to their concerns
um you know consult them when decisions
need to be
made in a meaningful way and more
important than that too i think there's
another layer of sort of pragmatic
arguments
if as experts you decide
that um it's not worth your time
talking with people you've now seeded
the entire public debate
to those who might very well have
interests very far afield
from yours and and that vacuum is filled
with other voices
i think we have a combination of um
responsibilities some of them are more
on i think a value in moral
grounding others are tactical and
pragmatic
um but i hope that we all recognize we
don't
need to be all engaging
in the same way um
that we have our own particular
approaches and our own particular niches
you know some of you some of us might be
wonderful on tv
does that mean everyone should be on tv
of course not um
but figuring out how you uniquely
can contribute what it is that you are
doing
and why it matters so much i think that
is
um ultimately a social good
well thank you liz this presentation has
been wonderful and
how can people get with you if they're
interested in learning more
yeah so it you can find me on uh twitter
my very unique username is just my name
at liz neely
but more importantly i encourage you to
go to storycollider.org
you can listen to our weekly podcast new
episode drops every friday
you can see our upcoming shows which we
are performing online every friday at
7pm
eastern time um and you can find
more about why and how we undertake this
wonderful mission in the world about
telling true personal stories about
science
to help humanize scientists illustrate
the scientific
process and correct the
you know over representation that we've
had for too long
in science by a very narrow set of
voices
we can do a much better job of
showcasing the reality
of science and research well thanks
again
and i want to remind the audience
there's another communications workshop
tomorrow at 5
30 it's how to use social media to get
out the word on your
brain research thanks again for coming
and thank you liz
thank you all